huit mois de guerre le président russe
ordonne aujourd'hui l'instauration de la
loi martiale dans les quatre territoires
Ukrainiens de daunès louance cresson et
zapporisia des régions annexées en
septembre dernier par Moscou la mesure
elle sera affectif à compter de ce jeudi
à minuit annoncé fête lors du Conseil de
sécurité on écoute la lumière Poutine
laissez-moi vous rappeler que la loi
martiale prévaut dans les républiques
populaires de Donetsk de Louhansk de
Kerson et de zapporigia depuis que
celle-ci sont entrés dans la Fédération
de Russie
il est donc nécessaire d'appliquer cette
loi du cadre légal russe j'ai donc signé
un décret sur l'entrée en vigueur de
cette loi martiale dans ces quatre
sujets de la Fédération de Russie